And with that, we are
done with this course.
Making a server and a client
communicate with each other
isn't that hard, but doing
it correctly, efficiently,
and securely is a
much more complex task
than it might seem.
We have covered a lot
of topics in this course.
We've taken a look at
the request and response
cycle, where the
browser and the server
get connected with each other.
Then we looked at HTTP's
verbs, headers, REST,
and performance issues.
Lesson 3 was on HTTPS,
TLS, and cryptography.
In the last lesson,
we look at HTTP/2
and all the amazing benefits
it brings to the web ecosystem.
In this lesson, we looked
at security precautions
with the same origin policy,
way to get around that policy,
and then some
vulnerabilities like CSRF
and cross-site scripting.
We covered a lot of techniques,
but the important thing
to keep in mind
throughout all of this
is keeping your user secure.
Thanks for joining us on
this journey of client server
communication.
We'll see you later.
Bye.